the Federal Aviation Administration it's
supposed to keep the skies safe for us
but the agency can't seem to figure out
how drones fit into the equation
Congress had asked the FAA to come up
with rules to govern the use of
non-military drones the deadline was
missed Bloomberg's editor-at-large Cory
Johnson joins us now with a look at
regulation gone wrong or not gone at all
not gone at all because it's been three
years since Congress fcfa to come with
regulations around drones and they
haven't got the job done now it's been
complicated a visual it's a complicated
very rapidly changing world because
there's so much innovation going on in
the world of drones and so many new
types of drums but they have been so far
behind the curve that they have been
able to figure out how to issue rules
about drones they've issued a lot of
sort of permits to a lot of companies to
try new things but the end result is
that there's now a growing back local
companies trying to find new ways to
apply drones to business and the FAA is
not giving them guidance so are they I
mean if you don't have regulation do you
just go ahead and do what you want to do
kind of ask forgiveness rather than
permission Allah uber or do you love
Matt Miller executor at more grown or do
you go and look for countries that are
more business-friendly in regards to
well we see a lot of big businesses like
Amazon doing is is just going overseas
think we're gonna have to develop this
somewhere else because we don't have the
guidance we've asked for from this
government so we're going to just going
to go somewhere else and take our
business to another country to develop
that so you see a lot of the drones
startups in America actually frustrated
by this we're about to talk to someone
on Bloomberg advantage radio now that he
was just stop watching TV while you're
on the TV but afterwards they can in
turn it a bloomer advantage radio and
listen to I'm gonna play you know I'm
gonna get I'm going to tell you I'm
gonna be honest with you right now oh I
even personally prefer radio to
television as far as getting my new i'm
not sure if i should say that as where
viewers looking at us now your your
lovely look at but my point is that with
it with a drawl business that the drone
business is actually moving overseas to
develop a lot of places that startups
are having a difficult time of it and
and furious about it because they really
want to grow this business they want to
do it domestically and they're knocking
the guide
wat for the FAA and the other aspect is
that we're seeing lots of unregulated
drone accidents a great increase because
it's tremendous fascination with the
drone drones period in the technology
around drugs that we're seeing a rise in
the number of incidents of drone safety
issues and the FAA has been recording
these dutifully they haven't given us
guidance on how we should actually
operate drones now these are serious
safety incidents I mean what are we
talking about here are their drones
crashing the seats at the US Open but
the the great concern here is that well
it was anyone seriously injured there no
but okay so but a drone then crashed
into a seat and might you know wound
your hand will have an entirely
different effect if it lands inside of
an engine of a jet and so because the
FAA hasn't issued the rules that the
Congress demanded of them three years
ago the drone operators are and the
drone businesses are concerned that
there's going to be an accident and it's
going to lead them Congress and then
demand that drones just be banned and
that's sort of the opposite approach
because you have use of drones in
agriculture its use of drones and
examining pipelines you have potential
uses of drones and all kinds of
businesses that are not being those does
not mean grown because its lack of sort
of guidance in the end what should be
legal to keep the dangerous activity
from happening and just to I mean just
the bottom line as to why the FAA hasn't
delivered these regulations is it saying
it's underfunded is it saying doesn't
have enough staff they have they say
they're studying it and they say they're
looking at it they haven't come up with
the answers of the industry's begging
for but the industry is certainly
begging there's a lot of venture capital
money going to these businesses because
the there are there are all these uses
of drones that could you know not just
the fantasy of DHL and Amazon doing
deliveries but it examining pipelines
for example all pipeline carriers are
required to examine all of their
pipelines on a regular basis and they
right now they fly Cessnas over these
things with special equipment to detect
leaks that's very expensive and very
inefficient they can do this stuff with
drones examining agriculture looking
what's happening crops and distant areas
great advantages to using drones and
these businesses and they're not this
business aren't growing the way that
they could because the guidance of the
FAA has been lacking